Nunca se sabe.
No, no,
nunca se sabe.
(Aplausos y ovaciones)
Gracias.
Hace poco tuve la gran oportunidad de hurgar en la inmensa mina de oro
que es la colección de canciones publicadas por Chess Records,
una compañía discográfica de Chicago, muy activa en los 50 y los 60 en EE. UU.
Esa música circuló por todo el mundo.
Los temas que voy a cantar esta noche
pertenecen a "Playing Chess", el álbum que acabo de lanzar
y que le rinde homenaje a esas canciones.
Estos músicos realmente inventaron el rocanrol, el soul y el R&B
tal como los conocemos hoy.
(Aplausos)
(Música)
(Cantando) Más allá de la montaña,
del otro lado del mar,
hay una chica que espera,
espera...
por mí.
(Música)
Cruzando el río,
más allá de todas las nubes,
más allá de los vientos.
Más allá de la montaña,
una chica me espera.
(Música)
Dile a las arenas,
a cada brizna de hierba,
por favor dile al viento que le abra paso a mi amor.
Más allá de la montaña,
una chica me espera.
Dile a la luna,
la luna allá en el cielo.
Dile a los pájaros que pasan volando
que mucho más allá de la montaña...
me espera mi amor.
Oh,
en cada noche oscura y estrellada,
oh, qué misterio
tan bien guardado.
Más allá de la montaña,
una chica me espera.
Dile a la luna...
la luna allá en el cielo.
Dile a los pájaros que pasan volando
que mucho más allá de la montaña
me espera mi amor.
En cada noche oscura y estrellada,
oh, qué misterio
tan bien guardado.
Más allá de las montañas,
me espera una chica.
Ella me espera.
Oh, ella me espera.
Lo sé, lo sé, lo sé, lo sé, lo sé.
Oh,
lo sé, lo sé, lo sé, lo sé, lo sé.
lo sé, lo sé, lo sé, lo sé, lo sé,
oh oh, oh oh.
(Aplausos y ovaciones)